service skates und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen videospiel heute wieder
jumping mit dem magic kapitel mit dem
baby jump league und wir haben eine
zuschauerin schweizer am start und zwar
die kindheits challenge ich entweder die
werden jetzt zeitgleich durch alle
module laufen das heißt wir beenden die
zeitgleich und wenn weniger als erste
mit dem modul fertig ist muss er warten
bis ich auch damit fertig bin und wenn
er jeweils das mobil beendet haben muss
der eine für den anderen deswegen als
kindheits challenge ein lied aus seiner
kindheit singen und derjenige für das
gilt für den das lied gesungen wird der
muss versuchen das team zu retten
chris reddy ich bin gleich da mund rede
ich mit ich will bekommen dass
rausgesprungen bist oder gar nichts sagt
david
soll ich anfangen ja gerne
okay wir machen was sie machen was das
kennst du okay okay okay was ich hab
heute ist ja okay ich will der beste
sein
pokémon ganz allein fange ich sie mir
ich kenne ich streife ok ok weiter
spitzenreiter jetzt ich streife durch
das ganze land und suche weit und breit
das kind aber jeder und sie verstehen
was sie diese macht verleiht kieler die
jetzt geboren werden werde niemals
pokémon kennen sie werden auf jeden fall
nicht so aus fliegen wenn sie die hymne
hört okay ich bin fertig angenommen okay
in einem unbekannten land aber ja ja
allzu langer zeit eine biene sehr
bekannt diese pläne genau wie bereits
das sind kinder zeitung ich bin okay war
daher wäre ich hab echt genau solch
herausgesucht
das ist saugut mann minute gefallen
daran habe ich gar nicht gedacht wie
eine mauer ist natürlich dass
kindheitserinnerung steht nummer eins
alter da hab ich überhaupt ich dann
gedacht worden
das war das habe ich früher immer
gesehen ja das war richtig klasse alter
sprechen noch viel mehr kennst du die
wissen wahrscheinlich nicht haben aber
ich habe ihn auch nicht niedriger sein
jetzt habe ich es heute früh gesprungen
ok wenn da wenn du bist schon weiter
gesprungen an angststörungen bitte guck
mal wo ich bin
seite gesprungen kommen zu dir bringen
okay okay
jawohl es nach ok macht mutig und
freundlich so tapfer und gal sich uns
recht kämpfen sie auch für dich eben im
wald unter bäumen und steinen in ihren
höhlen das sind sie zu haus
ich wollte sagen dass österreicher liegt
aber auch in den höhen
okay okay okay okay ich hab mich auch
okay das lied hey
wieso kennt sich das von alcon alter das
war der hit man brauche jetzt ein zwei
oder so hätte das wohl nicht meine welt
brauche junge bei mir war so der kiddy
contest und keine ahnung was noch
österreichische sachen halt auf
arbeitszwang über eine welt okay okay es
war brillant von akon das habe ich als
kind folge feiert okay also dass weiter
noch weiter
da unterscheiden sich so die welten
ruffy so aus dem bildungsbürgertum so
recken war bei ihm eine höhle ich noch
nicht kenne das modul nicht gefallen ein
bisschen schlechter setzten sich hier
ein katheter schönen bank okay
den speck und ok hier ist es okay tick
trick und track ist nicht der dax das
kino nein was 3 kann österreich ich weiß
nicht wer ist david hale sagt erich
stimmt sagt er ist ja die habe ich
direkt rick und rack und baguette gesagt
aber taktischen ach so dass hier schon
jetzt schwierig weil ich geh ich kenne
die songs nicht mehr auswendig aber auch
weiter erbringen
das muss ich mir das video dazu kämpfen
weiter ich will auch noch mal ansehen
meine hand hatten war für diesen fall
ist schon mal meine minecraft hinten
rechts an der wand noch respektiert ja
ich habe mich so ungesund ernährt das
machen bei kräften ist aber noch
diese eine sprung auf den einen helmut
blog damals nicht so wie sie vor dem
baum der blog ja genau genau da habe ich
auch echt schwierig hier oben christi
gute und ich warte auf meine ist da hab
ich auch das okay bin ansonsten holzmann
dahin ja wohl okay okay jetzt bin ich da
alles klar sollte sie früher wollte ich
war in irgendwelchen fallen ja aber das
kennt zum stimmt ok alles klar
okay okay hier bist du richtig
du bist wie ich dich geht es nicht das
ist doch ganz klar
jetzt stellt das waren kirchen die
nummer 13 das nicht erkannt
damit soll das echt coole somit wenig
leute weniger kämpfe jetzt forschen also
wenn wir uns den glauben wir uns okay
machen wenn einer von uns stirbt dann
muss der wieder ein lied singen
ja ja ja okay also noch welcher oder wir
können auch kreuz und quer verlierer sei
heute einfach lieder stunde um ihr baby
wäre gestorben
die hat es geheißen ich weiß wie es hieß
wir jetzt ab
take on me ach so ja der kombi sowie der
reform stört wenig kräftig stirbt wenig
boden also privat afrikas einfach
geradeaus und seine crew
das ist die dass es war irgendwas mit
dingen die fliegen oder genau richtig
was war captain balloon im flugzeug
valuation catalyst blickt halt immer so
von insel zu insel und machte damit
aufträge oder fernsehers 90ern da sie
wie gut die arena umfunktioniert ich
wusste einfach nur das mit fliegen ist
aber es gibt den sprechtagen gesangs
zeit in dem ding okay wenn ich das
nächste mal machen wenn ich sterbe oder
beziehungsweise am ende weil ich muss
darauf konzentrieren aber soll ich denke
glaubst du den gesangs teil bin sprecht
teil davon vortragen also wenn du es
geschafft hast dann ist es egal was
davon nehmen also muss einmal gesehen
macht und ruhm mann der dies alles
erkämpft hatte war hier nicht der
piraten
investiert wurde waren seine letzten
worte ihr wollt mal statt
dann sucht die decke die haben dann
war okay okay ich weiß wo ich mal so ist
ein schatz der welt versteckt ich weiß
ich weiß
und peter genau dass ich habe nie
geschaut aber das habe ich das habe ich
mit bekommen
ok 1 eine sache habe ich noch zeit für
ein tutu
und wie ging nochmal der sich die jungen
leute alter wie viele von den songs habt
ihr wieder der kader soll cantora hand
aufs herz
also für mich waren eine menge dabei und
wenig und eine beschreibung verlinkt wir
sehen uns bei der nächsten folge haut
rein macht's gut und ja